in 1879 charles darwin wrote to his
colleague joseph dalton hooker
about an abominable mystery in the
fossil record
he was perplexed at how rapidly major
families of flowering and fruit-bearing
plants
known as angiosperms emerged during the
cretaceous
over the span of just 10 million years
the oldest known fossils of angiosperms
date to around 135 million years ago
about 10 million years before this
explosion of diversity
now researchers are using tools in
molecular biology
and fossils to shed light on this
fascinating history
in 2019 researchers turn to chloroplasts
the organelle in plant leaves that
convert sunlight into energy via
photosynthesis
chloroplasts are a great tool for
understanding plant evolution
because it's easy to extract them and
sequence their dna
changes in that dna from species to
species can reveal how closely different
plants are related to each other
and when certain species and groups of
species evolved
researchers sequenced the chloroplasts
of plants from angiosperm clades
groups of plants with a common ancestor
they use the oldest fossil of major
clades to calibrate their molecular
analyses
next researchers analyzed genetic
markers in living plants to understand
when their genomes might have diverged
from their ancestors
this led to a much earlier date for the
origin of angiosperms
more than 200 million years ago in the
upper triassic
versus the oldest angiosperm fossils
which date to 135 million years ago
molecular analyses also suggest an
earlier explosion of angiosperm
diversity
in the late jurassic and early lower
cretaceous
another clue to this mystery comes from
the flowering plants helper
pollinators including butterflies and
bumblebees
as with angiosperms recent molecular
evidence has placed the origin of
pollinating insects further back than
the fossil record
the earliest fossil evidence for
lepidoptera for example
an order of insects which includes
butterflies and moths was from 195
million years ago
but molecular analyses suggest that
they've been around since 300 million
years ago
predating the new estimate of the origin
of angiosperms by tens of millions of
years
in the past researchers thought the
shift from wind pollination in
non-flowering plants
or gymnosperms to animal pollination in
angiosperms
led to more diverse flowering plants but
recent discoveries show that some
extinct gymnosperms were pollinated by
insects complicating the story
other questions remain including whether
certain characteristics implants
such as long floral tubes formed in
response to longer pollinator tongues
or the other way around the discovery of
new
fossils and studies that use similar
methods in calibration
could further illuminate exactly when
certain insects and plants
emerged for now the answer to darwin's
mystery
well over a century later it's still
complicated
you